MEMBERS, IF YOU WOULD LIKE
TO RESPOND TO THE ROLL CALL
ASK A QUESTION OR PROVIDE A
COMMENT
YOU WILL NEED TO RAISE YOUR AND
ACTIVATE YOUR VOLUME BUTTON ON THE DIAS
MICROPHONES. EACH MEMBER PRESENTING
TODAY WILL PROVIDE
AN OPENING AND CLOSING
STATEMENT
AND AS I PREVIOUSLY STATED
WITNESS WILL EACH HAVE TWO
MINUTES TO PROVIDE TESTIMONY. WE
WILL BE HEARING FOR BILLS ON THE
AGENDA TODAY THOSE WILL BE TAKEN
UP AND FILE ORDER. THE BILLS ARE
ON THE AGENDA ARE AB TWO NINE
FIVE. AB ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN. AB
TWELVE THIRTY TWO AND AB FIFTEEN
OH FIVE. AT THIS TIME. ASSEMBLY
MEMBER JONES SAWYER IF YOU WOULD
PLEASE BEGIN YOUR TESTIMONY. ON. EIGHTY TO NINETY FIVE. THANK
YOU AND GOOD AFTERNOON MEMBERS
ENOUGH MISTER CHAIR BOB THIS
BILL ESTABLISHES A WORKGROUP OF
HIGHER EDUCATION REPRESENTATIVES
FACULTY STAFF AND STUDENTS TO
DEVELOP A PROGRAM TO PROVIDE
FREE COLLEGE TO CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS. SPECIFICALLY THAT'S
WHAT EIGHTY TO NINETY FIVE FREE
COLLEGE DOES IN CARRYING OUT
THEIR WORK THIS WORKGROUP CAN
FOCUS ON DETERMINING WHICH
CAMPUSES WOULD BEST FIT TO
DEVELOP. PROGRAM MODEL
IDENTIFYING IF THERE IS ANY
PARTICULAR STUDENTS THAT WOULD
BENEFIT FROM THE PROGRAM AND
CREATE A MODEL THAT WILL WORK IN
TANDEM WITH THE EXISTING
FINANCIAL PROGRAMS SUCH AS CAL
GRANT. HISTORY OF COST
ATTENDANCE OVER FORTY FIVE YEARS
HIGHER EDUCATION CALIFORNIA'S
WAS PERCEIVED AS A PUBLIC GOOD.
STUDENTS WERE NOT CHARGE TUITION
BECAUSE THE STATE SOUGHT TO
ENSURE THAT THERE WERE AS FEW
BARRIERS AS POSSIBLE TO A MORE
EDUCATED CALIFORNIANS SOCIETY.
THE STATE HAS MOVED IN AN
ENTIRELY DIFFERENT DIRECTION
CONSIDERING CSU TUITION AND FEES
HAVE RISEN ONE THOUSAND THREE
HUNDRED AND 60% AND YOU SEE
TUITION AND FEES HAVE RISEN FIVE
HUNDRED AND 55% SINCE NINETEEN
SEVENTY NINE. ADDITIONALLY COST
OF ATTENDANCE SUCH AS FOOD
HOUSING HAVE RISEN 40% SINCE
NINETEEN SEVENTY NINE. FURTHER
ADDING TO THE ADDITIONAL STRESS
ON TO PENINSULA STRESSED OF
STUDENTS. DURING MY FIRST YEAR
AS AN UNDERGRADUATE IN THE
SEVENTIES ALONG WITH MR MEDINA.
TUITION IN THE UC SYSTEM WITH
ABOUT TWO THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED
AND SEVENTY NINE DOLLARS PER
YEAR. THIS GENERAL GENERATION
SHOULD NOT BE REQUIRED TO PAY
NINETEEN TIMES MORE THAN WHAT I
PAID BEEN MY PUBLIC SECTOR
COUNTERPART WAS REQUIRED TO PAY
FOR COMPARABLE EDUCATION. I WENT
TO UNIVERSITY SOUTHERN
CALIFORNIA DURING THE SEVENTIES
WE PAY THIRTY TWO THOUSAND
DOLLARS PER YEAR WHICH WAS A
HUNDRED FORTY EIGHT THOUSAND
DOLLARS- COMMITMENT OVER FOUR
YEAR- DURING THAT SAME TIME IN
THE SEVENTIES AGAIN. IT WAS TWO
THOUSAND NINE HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY SIX DOLLARS PER YEAR NOW
BERKELEY IS ABOUT FORTY THOUSAND
DOLLARS IN TWENTY TWENTY AND USC
IS IT SIXTY THOUSAND UC'S DOUBLE
BEARS. AND OBVIOUSLY THE UC
SYSTEM IS WAY UP TO A HUNDRED
SIXTY THOUSAND A YEAR AND TWO
OVER FOUR YEARS AND TWO AND
FORTY THOUSAND. FOR USC. PRESENT
DAY INSPIRED A PAST INVESTMENTS
EXISTING FINANCIAL AID DOES NOT
COVER ALL STUDENTS. AND MANY
REMAIN UNABLE TO AFFORD
ATTENDANCE AT THE STATE'S PUBLIC
UNIVERSITIES. AS THE CSU AND UC
SYSTEM HAVE CONTINUED FOR
PROSPER PROBE PROPOSED TUITION
AND FEE INCREASES AND ACOSTA
BASIC NEEDS IN THIS STATE HAVE
RISEN EXPONENTIALLY THE STATE
MUST CONTINUE INVESTING IN
FINANCIAL ASSISTANCE FOR
STUDENTS. AS A FURTHER EXAMPLE
IN RECENT YEARS A CSU STUDENT
WITH LOW INCOME WOULD HAVE TO
WORK TWENTY TO FIFTY FIVE HOURS
A WEEK THE COVERAGE NET COSTS OF
THEIR EDUCATION. COLLEGE
STUDENTS OFTEN HAVE TO CHOOSE
BETWEEN STUDYING OR WORKING TO
AFFORD THEIR TUITION AND LIVING
EXPENSES. CALIFORNIA SHOULD BE
IN THE BUSINESS OF STUDENT
SUCCESS AND NOT STUDENT STRESS
EXPANDING ACCESS TO. HIGHER
EDUCATION IS MUTUALLY BENEFICIAL
THE INVESTMENT FOR CALIFORNIA
FOR EXAMPLE THE BATCHES DEGREE.
INCREASES A PERSON'S EARNING
POTENTIAL BY 65% ACCORDING TO
THE U. S. BUREAU OF STATISTICS.
RICK INCREASES THE OVERALL TAX
CONTRIBUTION TO THE STATE. A IN
THE LONG TERM FINANCIAL
STABILITY FOR ALL. I APPRECIATE
QUESTIONS RAISED IN THE
COMMITTEE ANALYSIS AS WE MOVE
FORWARD HOPEFULLY WE MOVE
FORWARD I WILL CONTINUE TO WORK
WITH ALL PARTIES I WILL HAVE
DISCUSSIONS UNDER RELEVANT
ESPECIALLY THE TOP TEN
RECOMMENDATIONS AND ENQUIRES
THEY WERE BROUGHT UP BY THIS
COMMITTEE AND I WANNA THANK THEM
FOR THEIR WORK. I WILL HAVE
DISCUSSIONS WITH RELEVANT
STAKEHOLDERS TO CONTINUE WORKING
ON THIS ON THIS ISSUE I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR YOUR VOTE.
AND I THINK MY WITNESS. COULDN'T
COME IN PERSON. AND I DON'T
THINK YOU DO ON CALL SO I'M NOT
SURE WHAT MIGHT I DON'T KNOW
WHAT'S GOING ON NOW YOU'RE
SAYING YOUR WITNESSES NOT HERE
IN PERSON. IT COULD BE HERE
PERSON I THINK IF WE DO HAVE A
THE EIGHTEEN TO YOU MODERATOR
OKAY LET'S SEE IF WE CAN GET A
MINOR COLD IT IS SO IF WE WOULD
GO TO THE AT&T MODERATOR. FOR
THE WITNESSES AND SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE. BURKE IN THE CARE FOR
COMMON. WE DON'T HAVE ANY
WITNESSES AND HE COULDN'T ON THE
LINE RIGHT NOW. WE CAN TAKE-
PUBLIC COMMENT FOR SUPPORT SO IF
YOU LIKE YEAH LET'S GO TO LET'S
GO TO PUBLIC COMMENT THAT IN
SUPPORT. OR COMMENT IN SUPPORT
THEM AB TWO NINETY FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AT THE END ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN IS ONE ZERO. AND
THE O. LINE THIRTEEN YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. GOOD MORNING MR
CHAIRMAN MEMBERS RON RAPP
SPEAKING ON BEHALF OF THE
CALIFORNIA FACULTY ASSOCIATION
AND STRONG SUPPORT OF AB TWO
NINETY FIVE. I WAS ACTUALLY THE
MAIN WITNESS BUT FELT
UNCOMFORTABLE COMING INTO
COMMITTEES SO IF YOU DON'T MIND
I'LL GO HAD READ MY STATEMENT
IT'S ABOUT A MINUTE- PLEASE GO
AHEAD. OKAY THANK YOU- AB TWO
NINETY FIVE BUT YOU KNOW- WILL
CREATE A WORKING GROUP TO
DEVELOP A PILOT PROGRAM TO
PROVIDE FREE COLLEGE FOR
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS. MANY OF
CALIFORNIA STUDENTS PARTICULARLY
THOSE FROM LOW INCOME FAMILIES
FIND IT DIFFICULT IF NOT
IMPOSSIBLE TO AFFORD TO GO TO
COLLEGE. NOT ONLY ARE THESE
STUDENTS FINDING IT DIFFICULT TO
AFFORD TUITION FEES AND
TEXTBOOKS BUT A LARGE PERCENTAGE
ALSO REPORT THAT THEY STRUGGLE
WITH FOOD INSECURITY AND
HOMELESSNESS. CFA BELIEVES THAT
AB TWO NINETY FIVE WILL PROVIDE
THE LEGISLATURE WITH THE
INFORMATION THAT YOU NEED TO
DEVELOP A ROADMAP ON HOW WE CAN
ACHIEVE TUITION FREE COLLEGE
ACROSS THE VARIOUS MODES. OF THE
HIGHER EDUCATION COMMUNITY SO
THAT CALIFORNIA CAN PROVIDE MORE
STUDENTS WITH THE OPPORTUNITY TO
COMPLETE A COLLEGE EDUCATION IT
IS FOR THESE REASONS THAT WE
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST YOUR- VOTE
AB TWO NINETY FIVE. THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. EIGHT TO MODERATE ANY
OTHER WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON
THE PHONE LINES WAIT. WE HAVE NO
FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS TIME.
THANK YOU ARE ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM. C. NINE EIGHTEEN
ANTI MATTER CAN YOU SEE IF THERE
ARE ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
ON THE PHONE LINES. COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO A. B. TWO NINETY
FIVE PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN
ZERO THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE AND
THEN ZERO. AND WE HAVE NO
COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT THE
TIME THANK YOU AND ARE THERE ANY
WINNERS IN THE HEARING ROOM- ON
THIS BILL. SEEING NONE IF WE
COULD GO TO THE PHONES- EIGHTEEN
T. MODERATOR ANY TWEETERS ON THE
PHONE LINE ON THIS BILL. IF YOU
WOULD LIKE TO. PROVIDE COMMENT
PLEASE PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO
THAT COMMAND AGAIN ONE ZERO.
THERE ARE NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THIS TIME VERY GOOD
AND THEN WE'LL GO BACK. TO THE
COMMITTEE FOR ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. FROM THE COMMITTEE. DR
CHOI. THANK YOU ASSEMBLYMEMBER
AWFUL OF THE- OPPORTUNITY FOR
STUDENTS- TO EARN THEIR
BACHELOR'S DEGREE OF- WITH- NO
COST. BUT AS YOU KNOW THE MONEY
HAS TO COME FROM SOME SOMEWHERE
. I WAS WONDERING- FOR STUDENTS
TO BENEFIT FROM THIS OF FREE
TUITION FOR THEIR- A POST
SECONDARY EDUCATION. LISTENING
TO YOUR PROPOSAL- THINKING. IF
WE CAN. COME UP WITH A SOME-
SERVICE REQUIREMENTS SUCH AS
LIKE- WEST POINT- OR MILITARY
ACADEMIES. WELL AS FAR AS I KNOW
THE L. OR TUITION FREE AND-
REMOVED EVERYTHING PROVIDED. BUT
UPON GRADUATION THEY ARE
REQUIRED TO SERVE. THE COUNTRY.
FIVE TO SEVEN SOMETHING YEARS.
SO SIMILAR TO THAT. NOT JUST-
OFFERING FREE TUITION- NUMBER
RETURNED TO THE SOCIETY. I'M
GONNA EDUCATE YOU ORGANIZE- FOR
OUR CITIZENS WE ARE PAYING FOR
YOUR TUITION. AND THE SECONDARY
AND OPPORTUNITY MIGHT BE. I
KNOW- BUT TYPICALLY- RECENTLY.
WE HAVE A COME UP WITH US SO
MANY DIFFERENT KINDS OF CLUSTER
AND AIDS PROGRAMS. INCLUDING NOT
FEDERAL BRAND CYSTIC GRANTS
SCHOLARSHIPS AS SUCH. STOP MERIT
BASED SCHOLARSHIP OPPORTUNITIES
FOR THEM TO- WHAT CAR. RATHER
THAN OPENING FOR ANYBODY COME. I
MEAN WE ARE LIVING IN THE-
DEMOCRATIC CAPITALISTIC SOCIETY
WHERE- WE ONLY NEED TO COMPETE
AND WHAT CAR. WHEN YOU MAKE IT
THAT JUST TO OPEN. THIS SOUNDS
LIKE A PROVIDE PROVIDING
INCENTIVES ABOUT THE- IT COULD
BE UP RIVERSIDE. INCENTIVES NO I
CAN WALK INTO THE COLLEGES ANY
TIME I WANT THIS OPEN AND FREE
AN UNKNOWN KNOWING CENTERS. SO I
HAVE DONALD FOR THE TAX MONEY
THAT THE WE WILL BE EDUCATING
THEM THERE HAS TO BE SOME-
INCENTIVES AND THE MOST-
QUALIFICATIONS THEIR COMMITMENT
WHAT THEY WILL DO FOR THE
SOCIETY HAVE YOU THOUGHT ABOUT.
BOB AND THANK YOU DOCTOR CHOI
OF. THE EVEN GOT THIS IT'S IN IN
NINETEEN SIXTY THEN GOVERNOR
BROWN- DECIDED THAT IT WOULD
MAKE ALL. COLLEGE FREE BUT I
DON'T THINK HE UNDERSTOOD THE
ULTIMATE IMPACT ON THE ECONOMY
WITHIN FROM NINETEEN SIXTY TO
SEVENTY NINE- PEOPLE CONSIDER US
THE BEST EDUCATED WORK FORCE IN
THE WORLD. COMPANIES CAME TO
CALIFORNIA AND WE FLOURISHED THE
AMOUNT OF MONEY THAT CAME INTO
THE STATE BASED ON A WELL
EDUCATED- CALIFORNIANS
BENEFITTED US FINANCIALLY AND
HELP TO. BE ABLE TO PAY FOR IT A
LOT OF THIS AND SO THAT'S WHERE
THIS KIND OF IDEA CAME FROM THAT
IF WE GO AHEAD AND BETTER
EDUCATE EVERYONE. IN ADDITION- I
PUT THROUGH A BILL- BEFORE AND I
THINK MAYBE BEFORE YOU GOT HERE
CALL PAID FOR IT WHERE YOU WOULD
GO AHEAD. AND GET YOUR DEGREE
BUT THEN LIKE WE COME FROM AN
INSTITUTION WHERE PEOPLE MAKE
CONTRIBUTIONS TO THE ALUMNI
ASSOCIATION OTHERS AND WE COME
FROM AN INSTITUTION WHERE THEY
RAISED BILLIONS OF BILLIONS OF
DOLLARS FOR A RELATIVELY SMALL
GROUP. OF ALUMNI AND GRADUATE WE
WOULD THEN NOT TAX BILL WOULD
LOOK AT THE BENEFIT SOMEONE NOT
MAKING MINIMUM WAGE BUT THE NOW
MAKING- WELL OVER MINIMUM WAGE
NOW BECAUSE THEY NOW HAVE A
DEGREE. LOOK AT THE DELTA IN
WHAT THEY PAYING IN TAXES AND
THE INCREASE OVER THAT AND THEN
MAYBE USE THOSE FUNDS TO DO THAT
AND SO WHAT THIS COMMITTEE WOULD
DO WE LOOK AT ALL OF THOSE.
INCLUDING LOOKING AT PROVIDING
MORE DOCTORS. COULD COME AND
WORK IN MINORITY AREAS LIKE
MINUS LA PROVIDING MORE SOCIAL
WORKERS TO GO OUT AND DEAL WITH
THEM THE HOMELESS SITUATION OUT
THERE SO WE BILL THAT
INFRASTRUCTURE. MAY NOT ONLY THE
- WE'VE BEEN WITH RAY THEIR I
CAN DATA BECAUSE A WORKING
SERVICE ANOTHER PLACE. THAT
WOULD BE- THAT WOULD HELP. IN
THE LONG RUN SO I NEVER THOUGHT
ABOUT THEM THE MILITARY EXAMPLE
YOU GAVE IN- THAT IS SOMETHING
WILL DEFINITELY ON TAKE INTO
CONSIDERATION. THANK YOU VOICE
PLANNING I'M NOT DISPUTING. A
THE VALUE OF- EDUCATION
OBVIOUSLY EDUCATED PERSON IS A
MORE PRODUCTIVE AND OR
CONTRIBUTE TO MORE. BUT THE WHEN
YOU PROVIDE FREE TUITION. A MAN
IN THE COMMUNIST COUNTRY
WHATEVER YOU KNOW BUT THE
SOMEBODY HAS TO PAY FOR THAT SO-
I THOUGHT THOUGH IT WOULD BE
MORE INCENTIVIZING AND THE
TAXPAYERS SO- RESISTANCE OR
DATED LAST SO WHEN WE EXPECT
THEM TO RETURN SOMETHING. AND
ALL HIGH A BAR THE CONCEPT OF
FROM THE MILITARY ACADEMY STUFF
THAT THAT THE OPPORTUNITY TO
SERVE THE COUNTRY- UPON
EDUCATION UPON COMPLETION OF THE
PROGRAM SAID SO- THAT WAS
SOMEONE IDEA BUT I'M I'M TALKING
ABOUT THE- BECAUSE OF THIS WILL
BE AN ADULT TAX BURDEN FOR. ALL
OUR CITIZENS SO WHO ARE NOT.
NECESSARILY BENEFITING FROM THAT
. NO THE THIRD OF THE FAT OF WHO
WILL BE TAKING ADVANTAGE OF THIS
KIND OF. SO YEAH THAT'S OF
THAT'S SYSTEM THANK YOU
OPPENHEIMER A COUPLE BUT- WHAT
ABOUT THE- WELL ROUGHLY OUT GAS
AND THAN. FIFTY PER OPPOSITE SO
. ON NOT GOING TO TAKE A- OF THE
SO WHAT TO BAY. THE BURDEN OFF
WILL PAY MORE TO. GEN CONCERT
THANK YOU DOCTOR CHORE. ANY
OTHER QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM
THE COMMITTEE. C. NINE WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE- MISTER JONES
SAWYER. R. I AM EAGER TO
CONTINUE WORKING WITH YOU AND
MEMBERS OF THIS COMMITTEE-
MISTER CHAIR COMMITTEE STAFF
MEMBERS AND KEY STAKEHOLDERS IN
OUR SHARED COMMITMENT FOR
ENSURING ACCESS AND
AFFORDABILITY FOR ALL STUDENTS
MEMBERS I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR ITEM. THANK YOU- WE'LL GO
AHEAD AND TAKE A ROLL CALL HE
WOULD HAVE SECTOR. MEDINA
PRESIDENT CHOI. ARAMBULA BLOOM.
GABRIEL YEAH IRWIN KILEY LEVINE
LOW SANTIAGO GALLAGHER WEBER.
MMHM QUORUM IS PRESENT. DESERT I
CAN IN A SECOND SO WE HAVE A
MOTION THAT OF FIRST AND THE
SECOND- THANK YOU TO THE AUTHOR
FOR BRINGING THE BILL FORD ALSO
THANK THE AUTHOR FOR POINTING
OUT WITH THE FEES WERE WHEN HE
AND I AM IN COLLEGE BACK IN THE
SEVENTIES IT WAS ACTUALLY FORTY
NINE YEARS AGO WHO IS THE MOST
TO THE DAY THE NEXT STEP OR THAT
I AM ROLE THAT. UC RIVERSIDE-
AND I AND I WANT TO A- THAT.
WHEN I ENROLLED FORTY NINE YEARS
AGO THE FEES. THAT I REMEMBER
WRITING THE CHECK. WAS TWO
HUNDRED AND SEVENTY FIVE DOLLARS
A QUARTER- WITH WHAT I PAID I
THINK PRETTY MUCH UNTIL I
GRADUATED. IN NINETEEN SEVENTY
FOUR THE BUT THOSE ARE THE FEES
FOR TUITION NOT RIGHT OR RIGHT
DAHLE HAD A COLON YEAH OUR-
BOOKS. YEAH SO WE HAVE DONE A
LOT OF WORK TOGETHER RIGHT IS- I
THINK WE ALL ACKNOWLEDGE- TO
ADDRESS THE COST OF GOING TO
COLLEGE AND CERTAINLY WE ALL
AGREE THAT IT IS YOU KNOW-
BEYOND THE REACH OF MANY
STUDENTS AND FAMILIES- AND I
JUST POINT OUT THAT AND WE HAVE
HERE- THE CHAIR OF THE- BUDGET
COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION. AND THAT
WE'VE TALKED A LOT OF ABOUT DEBT
FREE- DEBT FREE GOING TO COLLEGE
AT PRE. AS OPPOSED TO JUST FREE
- AND SO I AM THANKFUL THAT THE
AUTHOR IS CONTINUE TO WORK WITH
THE COMMITTEE AND THE
STAKEHOLDERS- AND REFINING- SOME
OF THE DEFINITIONS AND THAT WE
CONTINUE TO TRY TO WORK TOGETHER
ON HOW BEST TO MAKE COLLEGE%
AFFORDABLE BUT I THANK THE
AUTHOR FOR BRINGING THE BILL
FOR- IF THE- MOTION BEFORE US IS
DO PASSED TO THE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE. AND MADAM SECRETARY
IF YOU WOULD CALL THE ROLL. THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA I CHOI. CHOI NOT
VOTING ARAMBULA BLOOM BLOOM HI
GABRIEL GABRIEL I IRWIN- WHEN I
KILEY. KILEY NARROW LEVINE LOW
LOW I SANTIAGO GALLAGHER.
CALAVERAS NOT VOTING WEBER.
WEBER I. SIX ZERO FOUR. SIX ZERO
THE BILL IS ON CALL I MEAN SIX
ONE SIX ONE THE BILL IS ON CALL
WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. THANK YOU THANK YOU
TAKE A MINIATURE. OUR OUR NEXT-
THE BILL IS AB BE ELEVEN EIGHTY
- WHEN YOU'RE READY.
THE BILL.
SECOND THANK YOU MISTER CHAIR A
COMMITTEE MEMBERS AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WILL INCREASE
ACCESS TO SUPERVISE TUTORING AT
THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BY AUTHORIZING COLLEGES
TO CLAIM FORTUNATE FOR STUDENTS
RECEIVING ASSISTANCE AND
CREDENTIAL OR DEGREE APPLICABLES
AND TRANSFER LEVEL COURSES
CURRENT LAW ALLOWS COLLEGES TO
CLAIM A PORTION FOR UNSUPERVISED
TUTORING ONLY IN REMEDIAL SKILLS
COURSES NOT FOR CREDIT BEARING
TRANSFER LEVEL COURSES THIS
FUNDING IS CRUCIAL TO ASSIST
STUDENTS SICK FOR TWO REASONS
ONE WE'VE EXPERIENCED A GREAT
DEAL OF LEARNING LOTS DURING THE
COUNT THAT MAKE AND STUDENTS
WILL NEED ADDITIONAL SUPPORT.
AND SECONDLY- MY BILL ABA SEVEN
OH FIVE WHICH WHICH REFORM FOR
MEDIAL EDUCATION PLACES MOST
STUDENTS DIRECTLY AND TRANSFER
LEVEL CLASSES AND IT IS CRUCIAL
THAT THEY HAVE THE TOOL OF
REMEDIAL EDUCATION AVAILABLE TO
THEM AND IT DOES NOT- REPLACE
OTHER FORMS OF CO REQUISITE FOR
CONCURRENT SUPPORTS WITH ME
TODAY HERE IN SUPPORT IS DAVID
O'BRIEN VICE CHANCELLOR FOR
EXTERNAL RELATIONS AT CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE AND BOUGHT DONALD ON
BEHALF OF A NUMBER OF COMMUNITY
COLLEGE. DISTRICTS YOU CAN GO
FORWARD. THANK YOU GOOD
AFTERNOON- CHAIR MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE I'M DAVID O'BRIEN VICE
CHANCELLOR FOR GOVERNMENT
RELATIONS FOR THE CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES WE'RE PLEASED
TO BE HERE TODAY TESTIFIED IN
SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN NOW KEEP MY TESTIMONY
FAIRLY BRIEF BECAUSE
ASSEMBLYMEMBER IRWIN ACTUALLY I
HAD A LOT OF THE IMPORTANT
POINTS BUT IN TWENTY SEVENTEEN
THIS LEGISLATURE DID TAKE
HISTORIC ACTION TO ELIMINATE
LONGSTANDING INEQUITIES IN
ACCESS TO. TRANSFER LEVEL
ENGLISH AND MATH BY ADOPTING A
B. SEVEN OH FIVE THANKS TO THE
LEADERSHIP OF ASSEMBLY MEMBER
IRWIN AND AS COLLEGES HAVE
IMPLEMENTED AB SEVEN OH FIVE AND
LOWER THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
ENROLLED IN THOSE PRE TRANSFER
LEVEL FORMALLY KNOWN AS REMEDIAL
COURSES THERE'S BEEN A DECREASE
IN THE NUMBER OF STUDENTS
ENROLLED. IN SUPERVISED TUTORING
EVEN THOUGH IT'S A PROVEN
EFFECTIVE TOOL TO SUPPORT
ECONOMIC SUCCESS- A STUDY
CONDUCTED BY THE CHANCELLOR'S
OFFICE ACTUALLY FOUND THAT THE
COURSE SUCCESS RATE FOR STUDENTS
WHO RECEIVE TUTORING IN BASIC
SKILLS ENGLISH AND MATH WAS ON
AVERAGE 8% HIGHER THAN STUDENTS
WHO DID NOT. AND AS THE ASSEMBLY
MEMBER REFERENCED CURRENT LAW
RESTRICTS APPORTIONMENT FUNDING
FOR THE SUPERVISED TUTORING-
COURSES AND THIS LIMITATION
ESSENTIALLY MEANS THE COLLEGES
DON'T HAVE THE FINANCIAL
RESOURCES TO EXPAND THIS
CRITICAL TOOL SO AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN WOULD REMOVE THIS
RESTRICTION REMOVE SOME OF THE
CONFUSION A CURRENT LAW THAT
YOUR- EXCELLENT STAFF ANALYSIS
REFERENCES. AND RESULT IN HIGHER
STUDENT COURSE COMPLETION AND
SUCCESS RATES SO JUST WANT TO
SAY THAT IT'S CONSISTENT WITH
THE PARADIGM THAT EIGHTY SEVEN
OH FIVE ESTABLISHES RECEIVE THE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER OR STAFF AND
THIS COMMITTEE STAFF AND. HAVE
AN ANSWER ANY QUESTIONS. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU TO MEMBERS MARTIN
MGI OUT. I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF
THE- INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS LISTED. IN
URINALYSIS AND I REALLY WANT TO
THANK THE AUTHOR OF THIS BILL-
FOR CONTINUING TO PUSH ON THIS
ISSUE I HAVE A BRIEF STATEMENT
FROM CASEY GARDNER. WHO'S VICE
PRESIDENT OF INSTRUCTION FOR
WOODLAND COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND
HE WASN'T ABLE TO BE HERE AT A
BANK MAKE IT BRIEF. BUT IT
WOODLAND STUDENTS TO USE
TUTORING AVERAGE AN ENTIRE
LETTER GRADE HIGHER. AND HAVE A
GREATER CHANCE OF PASSING THEIR
COURSES. IN ADDITION TO SUCCESS
TUTORING IS AN EQUITY FOCUSED
PRACTICE. 77% OF OUR TUTORING
STUDENTS ARE IDENTIFIED AS FIRST
GENERATION. 81% AS LOW INCOME.
AND 83% FROM DISPROPORTIONATELY
IMPACTED RACIAL AND ETHNIC
GROUPS- CURRENTLY COLLEGES CAN
ONLY GENERATE TUTORING. FOR
BASIC SKILLS COURSES WHICH GOES
AGAINST WHAT SEVEN A. B. SEVEN
OH FIVE WAS TRYING TO DO.
BRIEFLY THIS BILL WOULD INCLUDE
DEGREE OF POLITICAL APPLICABLE
ENTRANCE FOUR COURSES AS
ELIGIBLE FOR APPORTIONMENT
ACCOMPLISHING THREE THINGS
COLLEGES WOULD BE PROVIDED WITH
A RELIABLE FINANCIAL INCENTIVE
TO PROVIDE THE SCIENTIFIC
SERVICE. COLLEGES WOULD BE A BIT
ABLE ABLE TO BETTER SUPPORT
STUDENT SUCCESS AND ALL COURSES
ESPECIALLY TRANSFER LEVEL MATH
AND ENGLISH AND COLLEGES WOULD
BETTER AND BETTER COURSES
SUCCESS RATES LEAD TO SHORTER
COMPLETION TIMES FOR STUDENTS
SAY TAXPAYERS THE COST OF COURSE
COMPLETION. URGE YOUR SUPPORT
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. AT&T
MODERATOR IF THERE ARE. HELLO
LET ME FIRST GO TO- WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. IN NINE OKAY AT&T
MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD CHECK
THE- THE PHONES PLEASE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT. FOUR
COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE PRESS ONE
THEN ZERO AND THAT COMMAND AGAIN
BEFORE WE DO THAT THE MODERATOR
I'LL GO AHEAD AND I FORGOT TO
CALL FOR WITNESSES AND SUPPORT
WHO ARE HERE PHYSICALLY SO
PLEASE GO AHEAD. CALIFORNIA
THANK YOU GO AHEAD EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATE. LINE SIXTEEN YEAR MIKE
IS OPEN. RIGHT NOT GOING ANY
WITH THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE
LEAGUE OF CALIFORNIA TESTIFYING
IN SUPPORT. LINE SEVENTEEN YEAR
MIKE IS OPEN. GOOD AFTERNOON
CALLING ON BEHALF OF THE AT THE
CASE IN A CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE ADMINISTRATORS AND
SUPPORT THANK YOU. AN ONLINE
FOURTEEN. GOOD AFTERNOON MANY
RODRIGUEZ ON BEHALF EDUCATION
TRUST WEST A LITTLE DELAYS VIDEO
LETTER BUT WE ARE IN SUPPORT OF
A LOVING HE SAID THANK YOU. AND
WE HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT
THIS TIME. ARE THERE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN THE
HEARING ROOM. C. AND THEN WE'LL
GO TO THE EIGHTEEN T. MODERATOR
TO SEE IF THERE ARE ANY
WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION ON THE
PHONE LINES. FOR COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION. ONE THAN ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN. ONE ZERO. WE HAVE
NO COMMENTS COMING THROUGH AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY CLEANERS IN THE HEARING ROOM
. SEEING NONE ARE THERE ANY
TWEENER IS ON THE PHONE LINES
EIGHTEEN T. MODERATE. FOR
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS RELATING TO
A. B. ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO THE COMMAND
AGAIN ONE SEVEN ZERO. WE DO HAVE
ONE COMMENT COMING THROUGH IT'LL
JUST BE ONE MOMENT PLEASE WHILE
WE PROVIDE THEM WITH THEIR LINE
. SERVERS. JUST ONE MORE MOMENT
PLEASE. THE IN THE O. LINE
EIGHTEEN YEAR MIKE IS UP. GOOD
AFTERNOON LADIES THE YOUNGER
RIVERSIDE COUNTY COLLEGE
DISTRICT IN SUPPORT OF AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN. THANK YOU. AND WE
HAVE NO FURTHER COMMENT AT THIS
TIME THANK YOU- EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR I WILL GO BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE IF THERE ANY QUESTIONS
OR COMMENTS. ON THE BILL. C.
NINE- DESERVE A WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE YEAH I JUST PUT A GROUP
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE REALLY CLEAR
THAT SINCE- PP I SEE CAME OUT
WITH A REPORT LAST YEAR ON THE-
IT THE OUTCOME OF AB SEVEN OH
FIVE AND LITERALLY TENS OF
THOUSANDS OF STUDENTS THAT WENT
DIRECTLY TO TRANSFER LEVEL
CLASSES GRADUATED EARLY THEY
WERE ABLE TO PASS THOSE CLASSES
AND I GRADUATED EARLY. AND IT
WAS A VERY LARGE PERCENTAGE OF
STUDENTS OF COLOR SO WHAT WE'RE
DOING IS THE RIGHT THING WE JUST
WANT TO IMPROVE THE OUTCOME EVEN
MORE BY ALLOWING THEM ACCESS TO-
TUTORING. THANK YOU A MR WIN FOR
BRINGING THE BILL FOR IT I
COULDN'T AGREE WITH YOU MORE.
AND THANK YOU FOR CHAMPIONING.
OF THE MASSES OF SUPPORT TO OUR
STUDENTS. AS AS YOU SAID-
TRANSITION AWAY FROM REMEDIAL
EDUCATION WHICH KEPT STUDENTS
STOCK. HAD STUCK FOR YEARS- IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND WERE NEVER
ABLE TO GET OUT. OF SIGHT I
THANK YOU FOR- EVERYTHING YOU'VE
DONE IN THIS AREA. AND AND- KNOW
THAT THIS BILL- IS A
CONTINUATION OF YOUR BOTH TAKEN
THE STEPS TO PROVIDE SUPPORT FOR
ALL STUDENTS. BY ENSURING ACCESS
TO STATE FUNDED SUPERVISED
TUTORING. PROVIDING EDUCATIONAL
EQUITY AND PARITY CONTINUES TO
BE A PRIORITY FOR THIS COMMITTEE
AS IT IS FOR YOU. AND SO IT'S
FOR THAT REASON THAT I'M
SUPPORTING AB ELEVEN EIGHTY
SEVEN. ENCOURAGE MY COLLEAGUES
TO DO THE SAME. SO WE HAVE A
MOTION- BY MR LOW AND A SECOND
BY. MS VALID THERE'S A MAN
SECRETARY VIEWED PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE THE
MOTION IS TO PASS TO THE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE MEDINA
HI MEDINA HI CHOI. CHOI I
ARAMBULA BLOOM. BLOOM HI GABRIEL
IRWIN. IRWIN I HIGHLY HIGHLY AYE
LEVINE LOW LOW I SANTIAGO
GALLAGHER NOW THERE IS I WEBER.
WEBER HI. ONE EIGHT ZERO YOUR
pWILL GO TO A. B. TWELVE THIRTY
TWO MR MCCARTY. WHEN YOU'RE
READY. THANK YOU MR MEDINA AND
LOOK FORWARD TO GETTING BACK
WITH YOU IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
TALKING ABOUT. FOUR DOUBLE
HIGHER EDUCATION AT TODAY IS A
SIMPLE ADJUSTMENT FOR COMMUNITY
COLLEGES. AND THE ENROLLMENT FOR
IMMIGRANTS AND REFUGEES IN ESL
PROGRAMS AS A TECHNICAL CHANGE
WILL HAVE A HUGE DIFFERENCE FOR
MANY CALIFORNIANS AS YOU KNOW
THE AMERICAN CALIFORNIA THE HOME
OF IMMIGRANTS AT HOME OF. PEOPLE
COMING TO OUR COUNTRY ENGLISH
LITERACY IS THE KEY TO SUCCESS-
IT'S TRUE EVEN FOR HIGHLY
EDUCATED IMMIGRANTS WHO OFTEN
ARE FORCED TO WORK LOW WAGE JOBS
UPON THEIR ARRIVAL BECAUSE OF
THEIR- LACK OF KNOWLEDGE OF THE
ENGLISH LANGUAGE- THESE
INDIVIDUALS ARE ALL CURRENTLY IN
COMMUNITY COLLEGE ESL PROGRAMS
AND CREDIT AND NONCREDIT. BUT
FOR THE RECENT ARRIVALS THEY PAY
NON TUITION FOR THE CREDIT
COURSES THIS WILL ALLOW THEM TO
ENROLL A SOONER. AND PAY THE
MORE AFFORDABLE RATES FOR THESE
NEWCOMERS AND HELP THEM SUCCEED
AND FRANKLY HELP CALIFORNIA
SUCCEED- SO WITH THAT I ASK YOUR
AYE VOTE THIS AFTERNOON THANK
YOU. THANK YOU- WITNESSES IN
SUPPORT AND THE HEARING ROOM.
SEEING OKAY ONE ON THE LINE. WE
HAVE A WITNESS IN SUPPORT HERE
WELCOME TO COME FOR. YEAH THAT'S
FINE- WHICH WOULD BE UP. THERE
ON ALL CHANNELS ON THE BORDERS
OF ORDER OUT OF THIS AND-
SCHEDULED. OR THANK YOU. PLEASE
GO AHEAD. GOOD AFTERNOON MR
CHAIRMAN AND MEMBERS OF THE
COMMITTEE THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THIS OPPORTUNITY TO TESTIFY
TODAY ON BEHALF OF AB TWELVE
THIRTY TWO MY NAME IS CANARD
MCCORD AND I'M A THIRD YEAR LAW
STUDENT I MCGEORGE SCHOOL OF
LAW. CURRENTLY I'M A STUDENT OF
THE LAW SCHOOLS LEGISLATIVE AND
PUBLIC POLICY CLINIC AND WITHIN
THE FRAMEWORK OF THE CLINIQUE MY
COLLEAGUE AND I CAME OUT WITH
THIS BILL IDEA AND ARE VERY
THANKFUL TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY WHO AGREE TO CARE IT.
WE'VE BEEN WORKING ON THIS BILL
WITH MISTER MCCARTY'S OFFICE
SINCE AUGUST. I AM ARMENIAN AND
CAME TO THE UNITED STATES FIVE
AND A HALF YEARS AGO WITH MY
PARENTS. WHEN MY FAMILY FIRST
ARRIVED IN THE UNITED STATES WE
IMMEDIATELY REALIZED DAD BEING
PROFICIENT IN ENGLISH WOULD BE
ESSENTIAL FOR US TO SUPPORT
OURSELVES AND HAVE TO LIVE WE
CAME TO AMERICA TO PURSUE. EVERY
SINGLE IMMIGRANT WHO COMES TO
THE UNITED STATES WITHOUT THE
KNOWLEDGE OF ENGLISH.
UNDERSTANDS THE CHALLENGES OF
LEARNING ENGLISH WHILE
SUPPORTING THEMSELVES AND THEIR
FAMILIES. THE ONE YEAR RESIDENCY
REQUIREMENT FOR INSTITUTION
PLACES A GREAT BURDEN ON
IMMIGRANTS UPON ENTERING THE
UNITED STATES DO NOT HAVE THE
FINANCIAL RESOURCES. TO
ENROLLING ASL CLASSES MPD
NONRESIDENT TUITION TO
NONRESIDENT TUITION IS
APPROXIMATELY FIVE TIMES HIGHER
THAN THE IN STATE TUITION. MY
MOM WAS A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER
FOR FIFTEEN YEARS IN ARMENIA AND
WEBER FIRST ARRIVED IN
CALIFORNIA SHE COULD NOT AFFORD
TO PAY THE NONRESIDENT TUITION
AND ENROLL IN ACCREDITED ESL
COURSES SHE NEEDED TO HELP TO
GET HER ASSOCIATES DEGREE IN
EARLY CHILDHOOD EDUCATION AND
FULFILL HER DREAM OF RUNNING A
FAMILY DAY CARE. LUCKILY SHE'S
NOW RUNNING A SUCCESSFUL FAMILY
DAY CARE BUT SHE COULD HAVE HAD
IT EARLIER I'M NOT SACRIFICE
HERSELF IF SHE HAD THE CHANCE TO
TAKE ESL COURSES WHEN THEY FIRST
ARRIVE. THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME
THIS AFTERNOON AND I HOPE YOU
WILL SUPPORT AB TALL THIRTY TWO.
THANK YOU. ARE THERE ANY OTHER
WITNESSES IN IN THE IN SUPPORT
HERE PHYSICALLY. IF NOT WE'LL GO
TO THE- PHONE LINES EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR. WITNESSES IN SUPPORT
COP. FOUR COMMENTS IN SUPPORT OF
AB TWELVE THIRTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AT THE END ZERO THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE THAN EUROPE.
WE HAVE NO COMMENTS COMING
THROUGH AT THIS TIME ARE THERE
ANY WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION IN
THE HEARING ROOM. SCENE NINE
AT&T MODERATOR IF YOU WOULD SEE
IF THERE ARE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION ON THE PHONE LINE.
FOR COMMENTS IN OPPOSITION TO A.
B. TWELVE THIRTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO COMMENT
COMING THROUGH THANK YOU ANY
CLEANERS HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEEING NONE- EIGHTEEN T.
MODERATOR IF YOU'D SEE THERE ANY
WINNERS ON THE PHONE LINE. FOR
ADDITIONAL COMMENTS RELATING TO
AB TWELVE THIRTY TWO PLEASE
PRESS ONE THEN ZERO AT THAT TIME. AND WE HAVE NO COMMENT. THANK
YOU THEN TO THE COMMITTEE ANY
QUESTIONS OR COMMENTS FROM THE
COMMITTEE. SEEING NONE OF IT TO
THE OTHER MISTER MCCARTY IF
YOU'D LIKE TO CLOSE. THANK YOU
LIKE I WANT TO THANK MY WITNESS
HERE THIS AFTERNOON FOR
OUTLINING THE ISSUE THAT WE DID
THIS IN THIS COMMITTEE FOUR
YEARS AGO AS ANALYSIS AS MY BILL
FOR REFUGEES- THIS IS A
TECHNICAL ADJUSTED FOR OTHER
NEWCOMERS TO HELP THEM SUCCEED
UPON ARRIVAL IN CALIFORNIA SB
RIVAL THANK YOU THANK YOU. WELL
I'D FIRST LIKE TO APPLAUD-
PRESENTER HERE AND THE REST OF
THE STUDENTS AT MCGEORGE LAW
SCHOOL OF FOR THIS BILL IDEA. OF
MY PARENTS MOTHER AND FATHER
BOTH CAME TO THIS COUNTRY- TO
STUDY. AND I WILL NEVER FORGET.
OF MY FATHER'S ENGINEERING
BOOKS- YOU KNOW WE'RE WHICH WERE
IN ENGLISH. BUT ENGLISH WAS NOT
HIS FIRST LANGUAGE AND SO HE
WOULD HAVE MANY NOTES IN
SPANISH- IN HIS ENGINEERING
BOOKS AND GROWING UP. THAT MEANT
A LOT TO ME SO I AM VERY HAPPY
THAT THE AUTHORS BRINGING THIS
BILL FORWARD- IT IS CERTAINLY.
AT ALL AGES AND FOR ALL PEOPLE-
SO IMPORTANT RIGHT. THE MASTERY
OF ENGLISH SO THIS THIS BILL
PUSHES US IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.AND FOR THOSE REASONS
I AM VERY HAPPY TO SUPPORT THE
BILL THIS TODAY. SO WE'VE HAD A-
MOTION BY MISTER LOW. THE SECOND
BY MISS BALLOT. AND MADAM
SECRETARY. IF YOU'D PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. THE MOTION IS TO PASS
TO THE APPROPRIATE. MEDINA AYE
MEDINA AYE CHOI CHOI I ARAMBULA
BLOOM BLOOM I GABRIEL IRWIN
IRWIN I HIGHLY. KILEY NONVOTING
LEVINE LOW LOW I SANTIAGO VALID
ERAS. CALAVERAS I WEBER. YOU'RE
ONE SIX ZERO THE BILL IS ON CALL
FOR ABSENT MEMBERS THANK YOU. I
BELIEVE OUR LAST BILL. AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE. MISTER
RODRIGUEZ WHENEVER YOU'RE READY. WELL THANK YOU MR CHAIRMAN
MEMBERS. AND THANK YOU FOR
ALLOWING ME TO PRESENT AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE WHICH WOULD RE
BENCHED THE FACULTY OBLIGATION
NUMBER BETTER KNOWN AS FUNDING
CALIFORNIA COMMITTEE COLLEGES.
THE PHARMACY NUMBERS A FLOOR FOR
THE MINIMUM NUMBER OF FULL TIME
FACULTY EACH COMMUNITY COLLEGE
MUST HAVE. THE FARMERS DEVELOP
TO ENSURE COLLEGES AT A MINIMUM
INCREASE THEIR NUMBER OF FULL
TIME FACULTY WORK WORKFORCE.
PORTION TO THE GROWTH IN FULL
TIME EQUIVALENT STUDENTS
CURRENTLY ALL SEVENTY TWO
COMMITTEE CALLS DISTRICTS. ARE
OVER THERE FONG IN SOME CASES BY
THE HUNDREDS OF FACULTY. BARI
PENSION FUND WE CAN ENSURE THAT
FUTURE INVESTMENTS IN FULL TIME
FACULTY RESULT IN ACTUALLY
HIRING. NEW FULL TIME FACULTY
WITH ME TODAY PROVIDE TESTIMONY
AND HELP ANSWER QUESTIONS IS
STEPHANIE GOLDMAN ASSOCIATE
DIRECTOR OF FACULTY ASSOCIATION
OF CALIFORNIA TWENTY COLLEGES.
AND MICHAEL YOUNG LEGISLATIVE
ADVOCATE FOR CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS. THANK
YOU MISTER CHAIR MEMBERS MICHAEL
YOUNG WITH THE CALIFORNIA
FEDERATION OF TEACHERS- FIRST
LIKE TO THANK ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ARE YOU CONSERVING OF THIS BILL-
ESSENTIALLY AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE
AS THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER STATED IS
ABOUT REVENGE IN THE FACULTY
APPLICATION NUMBER TO THE
PRESENT VALUES- THAT FULL TIME.
FOR FULL TIME FACULTY AT THE
COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
ESSENTIALLY WERE TRYING TO
ACHIEVE IS- ACCOUNTABILITY AND
PROGRESS ACCOUNTABILITY AND
ENSURING THAT FUNDS THAT ARE
INVESTED FOR FULL TIME FACULTY
TO USE FOR THEIR INTENDED
PURPOSE. AND PRIDE RESOURCES 75%
GOLD OF 75% OF INSTRUCTIONAL
HOURS BEING TAUGHT A FULL FIVE
FULL TIME FACULTY AND CALIFORNIA
COMMUNITY COLLEGES. IT WAS
PREVIOUSLY STATED- PRESENTLY
WHEN FUNDS ARE DISTRIBUTED TO
THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE DISTRICTS
FOR THE GOAL OF GETTING CLOSER
TO A 75% GOAL NOT ALL OF THOSE
PLANS ARE USED. FOR TIME BACK SO
S. YOU WERE TRYING TO DO IS I RE
THE FOR. INSURING THAT PLANS ARE
USED FOR THEIR INTENDED PURPOSE-
AND FOR THOSE REASONS WE
RESPECTFULLY ASK RIVAL THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. GOOD CHAIR AND
MEMBERS I'M STEPHANIE GOLDMAN IN
THE- DIRECTOR OF RED FACT. THE
TWO THOUSAND FIFTEEN. BUDGETING
A SIXTY TWO MILLION DOLLARS FOR
FULL TIME FACULTY HIRING AND WE
SAW EVEN MORE INVESTMENT IN FULL
TIME FACULTY HIRING INTO THE
200-018-2000 EIGHTEEN. AND THEN
AGAIN LAST YEAR IN THE TWO
THOUSAND TWENTY ONE AND TWENTY
TWO. BUDGETS DESPITE THE
SIGNIFICANT INVESTMENT IN OVER
THIRTY YEARS SINCE AB SEVENTEEN
TWENTY FIVE CALIFORNIA HAS STILL
NOT REACHED THE SEVENTY FIVE
PERCENT. FULL TIME INSTRUCTIONAL
. FACULTY ARE KEY TO STUDENT
SUCCESS IN KEEPING STUDENTS
ENROLLED WHEN FACULTY ARE
EMPLOYED FULL TIME THEY'RE ABLE
TO SPEND MORE TIME ON THEIR
CAMPUSES. THANK AGE WITH THEIR
STUDENTS MORE AND THEY CAN HOLD
THAT OUR OFFICE HOURS. AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE WOULD CORRECT TO
THIRTY OR IN EQUITY THAT
RESULTS. IN THE IN A PROBE IN
ACCURATE REPORTING OF THE TOTAL
NUMBER OF FULL TIME FACULTY
TEACHING IN THE COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS. UNDER THE
EXISTING FONG FORMULA COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS ARE DIS
INCENTIVIZED FROM INCREASING THE
PERCENTAGE OF INSTRUCTION.
TAUGHT BY FULL TIME FACULTY.
DISTRICT FIVE HAS LONGSTANDING
STATE POLICY EVEN WHEN THE
LEGISLATURE APPROPRIATES FUNDS
SPECIFICALLY FOR THIS URPOSE.
AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE WILL. CORRECT
THESE INEQUITIES BY THREE
PENSION FUNDS PRESENT VALUES.
THANK YOU. ANY OTHER WITNESSES
IN SUPPORT. HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. SEEING NONE IF WE GO TO
THE AT&T MODERATOR FOR ANY
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT ON THE
PHONE LINES. FOUR COMMENTS IN
SUPPORT OF AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO. THAT
COMMAND AGAIN ONE TEN ZERO. AND
A LINE OF FIFTEEN YOUR
MICROSCOPE. AFTERNOON SHERRIN
MEMBERS NUMBER LET ME SAY ON
BEHALF OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION IN SUPPORT. WE HAVE
NO FURTHER COMMENT. THANK YOU
ARE THERE ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION HERE IN THE HEARING
ROOM. C. NINE EIGHTEEN TO
MODERATOR WE COULD GO TO THE
PHONE LINES FOR ANY WITNESSES IN
OPPOSITION. BURKE COMMENTS IN
OPPOSITION TO AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE
PLEASE PRESS ONE THEN ZERO
RECOMMEND AGAIN ONE THEN ZERO.
WE HAVE ONE COMMENT COMING
THROUGH ONE MOMENT PEOPLE WILL
BE PROVIDE THEM WITH THEIR LINE
NUMBER. AN OUTLINE THAT NINETEEN
YEAR MIKE IS OPEN. MEDINA
MEMBERS ARE DAVID HAWKINS I'M
THE LEGISLATIVE ADVOCATE FOR THE
CALIFORNIA COLLEGE DEPENDENCE-
WE REPRESENT ABOUT TWELVE
THOUSAND FACULTY TEACHING- CLOS
TO A HALF MILLION STUDENTS WE'RE
ACTUALLY IN SUPPORT- I DIDN'T
QUITE GET TO Q. CORRECTLY- OF AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE ACTUALLY
CORRESPOND TO AN ASTEROID BELT.
THANK YOU MODERATOR MODERATORS
ANY OTHER WITNESSES ON THE LINE
. WE HAVE NO OTHER WITNESSES AT
THIS TIME THANK YOU ARE THERE
ANY WINNERS PRESIDENT. MMHM C.
NINE EIGHTEEN TO MODERATOR IF
THERE ANY WINNERS ON THE LINE.
FOR ADDITIONAL COMMENTS RELATING
TO A. B. FIFTEEN OH FIVE PLEASE
PRESS ONE AND THEN ZERO AT THIS
TIME. AND WE HAVE NO COMMENT
COMING FOR A- TO THE MEMBERS OF
THE COMMITTEE ANY QUESTIONS OR
COMMENTS. THANK. A MISTER
RODRIGUEZ- IF YOU'D LIKE TO
CLOSE. THANK YOU MEMBERS ARE
STRUCTURE I'VE. THANK YOU MISTER
RODRIGUEZ AND THANK YOU FOR
BRINGING THIS BILL FORWARD-
NINETEEN EIGHTY FOUR I GOT MY
MASTERS IN HISTORY AND AT THE
URGING OF MY PROFESSORS I- MADE
SURE THAT I WAS ABLE TO TEACH-
AT THE COMMUNITY COLLEGE AND I
DID. PART TIME. AND I TAUGHT
PART TIME FOR SEVERAL YEARS AND
I KNOW THE STRUGGLES OF PART
TIME FACULTY AND THAT IS NOT
KNOWING FROM YEAR TO YEAR HOW
MANY CLASSES YOU'RE GONNA TEACH
BEING ABLE TO BE TERMINATED AT
ANY TIME HAS HAPPENED TO ME ONE
ONE YOU'RE GOING TO TEACH TWO
CLASSES AND AS I WAS IN THE
DRIVEWAY ON MY WAY TO THE
COLLEGE I WAS INFORMED THAT
INSTEAD OF TEACHING TWO CLASSES
I'D BE TEACHING ONE CLASS AND MY
SUMMER INCOME WAS CUT IN HALF
NOT HAVING OFFICES. NOT HAVING
SPACE TO PREPARE- NOT BEING ABLE
TO MEET WITH STUDENTS SO WE ALL
KNOW THE IMPORTANCE OF FULL TIME
FACULTY AND HOW MUCH BETTER
STUDENTS DO WITH FULL TIME
FACULTY BECAUSE OF ALL THE
ADVANTAGES THAT FULL TIME
FACULTY OF BRING INCLUDING THE
COMMITTEE WORK THAT FACULTY DOES
ON CAMPUSES BUT HAVEN'T BEEN A
TRUSTEE AS WELL I KNOW THAT THAT
THIS IS A LA AND I WROTE DOWN
THAT WAS PASSED THIRTY YEARS AGO
BUT IT IS STILL NOT IT HERE TOO-
BY COMMUNITY COLLEGES SO I THINK
THIS IS AN IMPORTANT BILL THAT
MR RODRIGUEZ IS. A BRINGS
FORWARD AND I CERTAINLY
SUPPORTED WE HAD A MOTION- BY MR
LOW SECOND BY MISS VALLADARES-
THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE IF THE
- SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL
. THE MOTION IS DUE PASSED TO
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
MEDINA HI MEDINA I CHOI CHOICE I
ARAMBULA BLOOM BLOOM HI GABRIEL
GABRIEL HI IRWIN- WHEN I KILEY.
KILEY I. LEVINE LOW LOW ALLY
SANTIAGO SANTIAGO HI BALLADARES
MILITARES I WEBER. YOU'RE A NINE
ZERO YOUR BILL IS OUT THANK YOU
. NOW WE WILL GO BACK TO- BILLS
THAT WERE ON CALL. OKAY AND IF
IT IF I COULD ASK THE SERGEANTS
TO PLEASE- CONTACT THE ABSENT
MEMBERS SO THAT WE WON'T HAVE TO
BE HERE TO LOCK. WE SHOULD. YEAH
AB TWO NINE FIVE ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I LEVINE SANTIAGO
SANTIAGO HI THE VOTERS. EIGHT
ONE. YES- YOUR AVAILABLE TO AT
THE TOP OF. PRESTON OKAY EIGHT
ONE A. B. TWO NINE FIVE IS OUT
WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR A FEW
MINUTES FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. I
JUST DID THE REST YEAH WE'LL
KEEP GOING. THE AB EIGHTY SEVEN
ARAMBULA ARAMBULA. GABRIEL
GABRIEL AYE LEVINE SANTIAGO.
SANTIAGO I'D. WE STOLEN SO AB.
ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN ELEVEN ZERO
THE BILL IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE IT
OPEN- FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. AB
TWELVE THIRTY TWO ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA HI GABRIEL. GABRIEL I
LEVINE SANTIAGO WEBER. IT'S UP
TO ELEVEN. NINE ZERO AB TWELVE
THIRTY TWO IS OUT WE WILL LEAVE
IT OPEN FOR ABSENT MEMBERS. AB
FIFTEEN OH FIVE. ARAMBULA
ARAMBULA I LEVINE. WEBER. TEN
ZERO AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE IS OUT
WE WILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. BUT ALL THE OTHER
PRODUCTS THAT YOU GOT THE MONEY
TO. OKAY AB. TWELVE THIRTY TWO.
LEVINE WEBER. WEBER I. TEN ZERO
AB CLUB THIRTY TWO IS OUT AND
STILL LEAVE IT OPEN FOR ABSENT
MEMBERS. AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE
LEVINE WEBER WEBER AVE. FOR
ELEVEN ZERO A. B. FIFTEEN OH
FIVE IS OUT TO LEAVE IT OPEN FOR
A FEW MINUTES FOR ABSENT MEMBERS
. THE GREAT. ARE ONE OF. IF
THERE VERY LITTLE. YEAH THE
LITTLE YEAH I PROVIDER WILL BE
ON THE FOLDER CARE YEAH HEY OKAY
. THEY SISTERS AND BROTHERS
DEVOTED ON. THIS DEVELOPING.
YEAH- OVER THE- I APOLOGIZE TO
YOU SEE. RIGHT RIGHT. AB IS
NORMAL. RIGHT.
YOU DID YOU WANT
OKAY. OKAY AB TWO NINE FIVE
LEVINE LEVINE I. TEN TEN ONE
BILL EIGHTY NINE ONE NINE ONE AB
TWO NINE FIVE IS THAT. AB ELEVEN
EIGHTY SEVEN LEVINE. TWELVE ZERO
AB ELEVEN EIGHTY SEVEN IS UP. AB
TWELVE THIRTY TWO LEVINE. ELEVEN
ZERO A. B. TWELVE THIRTY TWO IS
OUT. AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE LEVINE.
WELL ZERO AB FIFTEEN OH FIVE IS
OUT THANK YOU MR LEVINE. SO I
WANT TO EXTEND MY GRATITUDE TO
THE SPEAKER'S OFFICE STAFF THE
RULES COMMITTEE STAFF THE
LEGISLATIVE DATACENTER. THE AT&T
MODERATOR AND ALL WHO ENSURE THE
HEARING COULD TAKE PLACE. IT'S
HARD TO BELIEVE THAT WE'RE INTO
YEAR TWO OF THE PANDEMIC LET US
CONTINUE TO BE ENCOURAGED AND
KNOW THAT WE WILL WEATHER THE
STORM OF THE PANDEMIC. TOGETHER
THE ASSEMBLY HIGHER EDUCATION
COMMITTEE. VISIT YOUR.